clayton kershaw
228 era is
or 215 era is good for fifth in the
national league his whip which is walks
and hits perennians pitched
number one in baseball first and third
one gone here's rendon swings in the
ground ball back hit it by turtle throws
to second out at second on the first and
a double play five four three
beautiful play started by turner
terrific pivot by hernandez one hop
throw to muncie rendon is done and so
are the angels andrew heaney is on the
mound for the angels 12th start
he's four and three with a 402 era and
he's thrown the ball very very well over
his last five stars really it's his
fastball so here's mookie betts who's
hitting 293 16 homer's 39 driven in
ini's first pitch is a ground ball base
hit in the left field that didn't take
long bets is a board with a single to
look they're at the corners with two
guys there goes muncie pitches up and in
stats he throws to second and the
dodgers get the game's first run as the
ball bounces off the run he folds wide
that allows feds to score and the next
batter will be the nine-hole hitter the
catcher austin barnes this one is lifted
in the air into right center field
should be an easy play under making the
grab on that one is taylor ward and that
is how the inning will end so the fly
out to right will wrap it up and so the
angels have runners now at first and
third with two away and mike trout will
be the batter lifts a high fly ball that
ball's carrying deep out into left
center field it is trouty here
mike trout gets kershaw right there
he hits a three run homer that's the
first home run and first rbis he's ever
had in his career against kershaw a big
hit right there gives the angels a 3-1
lead here's two out nobody on and turner
is coming up and there's a fly ball deep
down the left field line headed toward
the dodger bullpen and into it a home
run his third home run of this season
makes it 3-2 with justin turner he has a
lot of inside out swings and there are
some pitchers that think aha on the head
of it as he was one ball and two strikes
i think they'll try and throw the
fastball by and
bust him inside with it
wrong idea his first long ball since
august 12th extending the nba streak to
29 games
upton will lead it off against clayton
kershaw justin up the skies went out to
deep left field and pollock is back and
go on big fly for justin
that got back to the first road just
behind the wall out there the left
fielder pollock went back to the wall he
was ready to jump up and then realized
he had no chance to get it upton with a
lead off homer angels of homer in
back-to-back innings now against kershaw
ninth of the year for upton and the
angel lead now goes to four to two
nights for kershaw is over
as grouderal will take over and the
first batter up for the angels lifts a
high fly ball to deep right center field
and jared walsh has just hit one out a
home run his ninth of the season
first pitch there from grader all
and the angels now live homered in three
straight innings aj pollock will be
leading it off andrew heeney's first
pitch
there's a fly ball the left field upton
going back to the wall he looks up and
that one's gone a home run
aj pollock his 14th home run of the year
the dodgers are back to within one it is
4-3 angel
college just continues to put the ban on
the ball with some authority turner
leading it off at the bottom of the
fifth turner hits another one to deep
left field he has doubled his homework
tonight
turner's second home run and his many
at-bats he had two home runs all season
coming into the game they have a runner
at first through the dodgers with no
outs yes smith for the fly ball to left
field that's on its way and that one is
gone a home run
will smith into the dodger bullpen
and the dodgers have taken the lead it's
six to five for the dodgers their fourth
home run of the night and for smith his
seventh home run of the year
back-to-back waltz with two out peterson
who's pinching
peterson rifles one through the left
side pinch it rbi hit
will smith into score and the dodgers
string it together with two out
he gathers some insurance here in the
seventh dodgers leading the angels seven
to five two out secret first edwin rios
the hitter and he swings and a fly ball
to right field way back and it is gone a
home run edwin rios hits the home run
the hits just keep on coming dodgers
working nine to five
elimination number one for the angels
any astros win and the angels loss would
end their postseason hopes and now the
angels are down to their final out in
this ball game
it's a bouncing ball to first hernandez
to the bag and that does it
the dodgers hit five home runs and went
9-5 with the angels glimmer of hope for
the postseason